hi there steve kaufman here um
get my
blue snowball a little closer
um
i haven't done a video for a while and
um
the other day i printed on my on my blog
i put up some pictures of a meal that i
cooked and
berta in madrid
uh she said that she misses my videos so
uh you know it doesn't take much
encouragement uh if there are people out
there who enjoyed
uh watching i'm quite happy to get on
here and uh and rant
so i was just looking at some of the
subjects that have come up recently on
my blog
one of the ones i'll mention is this
whole issue of critical thinking versus
sort of
the emotional connection that we might
have with the language
and i've mentioned on my blog some of
the exchanges that i've had with some
teachers who are on a
list serve which is a
sort of a community of people who send
emails to this broad distribution of
people who are following
and talk about things that relate to
language learning
and
the subject always comes up of how you
know there's this sort of
uh scope creep where the teachers don't
want to just teach the language or help
people learn the language they want to
teach them about democracy or they want
to teach them about their rights and
about social inequality or they want to
teach them to analyze better and and
they feel that they're in a position to
do this that somehow that an english
teacher is more
is is better at critical thinking than
someone from a different culture who
just doesn't happen to speak
english
um
and so that was one series and i'll get
back to that subject
and then there was this idea of that
appeared in an article that i posted
some work done i think in israel which
demonstrated
that how we feel about a language or
about the people has a major impact on
our ability to pronounce accurately on
our ability to reduce our accent so to
speak
and i think this is very interesting
because
obviously how well we do in learning a
language is very much influenced by how
we feel
our level of motivation our level of
interest and and even beyond that our
level of empathy with the language
and as one of the people who commented
on my blog said you know our desire or
willingness to see ourselves as part of
that group and i have always felt that
to be very significant
when i learn chinese i see myself as
chinese i have no trouble
seeing myself as one of them they may
not want me
or koreans or russians or whoever but i
don't care if i listen to ejamuskv and i
and i hear all these people i'd love to
go there and meet them and go out for
dinner and talk russian they may not
want anything to do with me
but but that's a different story in my
mind i can see myself as part of their
group
whether they would accept me as part of
the group in a way doesn't matter
and uh yeah i might face rejection that
might discourage me a little bit but in
a way it doesn't i just want to be part
of their group whether they want me or
not
and that kind of sort of emotional
commitment is very important
on the other hand
the idea that the language teacher has
to be the teacher of a new way of
thinking of a different culture has to
introduce the culture to it to you i
have always resisted that
if i was when i went to japan i actually
had for one month i went to
uh for an hour i think twice a week a
japanese class just under is underneath
tokyo tower
and the teacher there wanted to tell me
about japanese festivals and i can still
remember his kokuro kokoro and
all kinds of stuff like that about the
japanese and how they are
it was meaningless to me it didn't
i didn't want him
to
impose that on me i wanted to discover
it on my own
through the japanese people that i met
through the reading that i did
i didn't want to have it imposed on me
and so and maybe i'm
different or strange in that regard
but i always feel that any feelings that
we have that are natural
any desires that are genuine
are going to be much more powerful
motivators in learning
than something that is taught at us
instructed to us
so i picture these teachers
teaching and they don't really call it
critical think they call it higher order
thinking like they are going to teach
higher order thinking that suggests that
they are already practitioners of higher
order thinking and that their students
only practice lower order
thinking
i mean we all practice thinking
critical thinking i mean this thing cost
ten dollars and this costs five so if
this one isn't twice as good as that i
won't buy it i'll buy the cheaper one i
mean we're doing that all the time
um
but the people on this list are very
very insistent they're all without
exception and the other thing that's
funny on this list service because
everything that happens in the public
domain
insofar as language or any kind of
education is concerned it's
fundamentally driven by how do we get
more funding
and once funding stops the activity
stops
and this particular list serve is funded
and one of the things they fund
is a person to monitor every post
so that every so often i get one of my
posts because i send it an email there i
get it rejected
some while ago one of my posts was
rejected because i had the words in
there
you know sometimes it's useful to
consider both sides of an argument i
think i said something like that she
said please remove that
now here again
uh someone on this list serve
came along and said that the american
occupation of japan
after the war
is largely responsible for the japanese
approach to teamwork
and consensus building
so i went back and i said that
i did not think that a few years of
american occupation could have any such
influence
on japanese culture that was just not so
so then we had a back and forth and
someone else chimed in and he had a
bunch of
information about how
japan continues continues to operate on
a top-down military-style
you know management of management and
that the honcho is the man in charge and
everybody's afraid to challenge the
honcho and so i went back and said well
no actually there is no one there is no
such position as a honcho there's a
kacho there's a bucho there's no hancho
and
besides which in japan the the ideal is
consensus
uh
i think there's more military order
giving
type management in the u.s or canada
than there is in japan in my experience
and i lived there for nine years but you
also can have very dictatorial
management styles and different
companies different situations but by
and large the effort is to arrive at
some kind of consensus
and
but the japanese there is dissension
there is insubordination and i used as
an example the situation leading up to
the second world war
where the
sort of dissent
and the insubordination by a certain
group of hot-headed officers is largely
responsible for this sort of
increasingly aggressive posture
and aggressiveness and aggressive action
by the japanese military prior to the
war
and so i get a note back from the person
monitoring his farm
would you please remove your reference
to hot-headed officers because some of
the members of our group
may have connections with hot-headed
officers and may find that offensive
i kid you not that's what she said
so i i mean i've long since stopped i
don't argue with him i just but okay no
hard-headed officers just mid-level
officers whatever but that's just
unbelievable
you know
critical thinking but you can't
describe something that is true that is
historical fact
uh that probably is irrelevant to most
people on the farm anyway i'll leave the
subject
so i guess what i want to get at here
again is i don't want to belabor the
point that that
you know
the key thing for a teacher is to engage
the emotions
of the learner
and that is best done by somehow trying
to stimulate them so if if some
discussion critical discussion of i
think one of them said that they want
they want their learners to learn to be
able to maturely discuss ethical
questions well if the learner is
interested in discussing ethical
questions fine but if they want to talk
about cooking gossip
uh
travel whatever let them talk about what
they want
and let them find the things in your
culture that they find attractive don't
try to persuade them what they should
find
attractive because all
the main thing in teaching a language is
to turn on the switch
and that's what teachers should be
thinking about all the time how do i
turn on each person's switch now easier
said than done if you've got a room full
of apathetic teenagers but i'm about to
run out of time bye for now